cuál es tu animal favorito el modo el
modo o dios mío está en tiernas
reunimos a siete madres adolescentes
soy madre adolescente soy madre
adolescente soy madre adolescente soy
madre adolescente adolescente soy madre
adolescente
andrew adolescente yo soy madre
adolescente hay una impostora si el
grupo descubre quién es ganará un premio
en efectivo si la impostora sobrevive se
gana el premio en efectivo esto es el
impostor el impostor
[Música]
cuando tienes un bebé te cambia la vida
así lo que diferenciará la impostora de
la verdadera madre adolescente serán los
detalles has perdido o ganado amigos
estás con el padre de tu bebé sin duda
yo no tendría ni idea qué ocurre durante
la etapa del parto o después del parto y
cosas así sin esfuerzo además van a
sospechar de mí y van a pensar que estoy
exagerando me siento segura pero estoy
nerviosa la impostora tal vez sea una
niñera o quizás una hermana mayor
hola
cuántos años tienen los bebés o nosotras
ambos cumplí 18 en agosto y mi bebé
tiene 10 meses pero cumple 11 mañana
casi un año increíble qué emoción yo
tengo 15 y mi bebé 4 meses tengo 19 y mi
hija acaba de cumplir 21 meses hoy tengo
17 y tengo uno de 18 meses tengo 19 y
tengo una hija de dos años acabo de
cumplir 18 mi hija tiene dos y medio
cumplió 12 en abril tengo 14 y tengo una
bebé de 18 meses y cumple un año en
marzo cómo fue la experiencia de ustedes
cuánto tiempo duró su trabajo de parto
yo estuve 47 horas fue terrible pero
valió la pena estuve en trabajo de parto
por 11 horas tengo en vida la luz no es
broma se pusieron la epidural o tuvieron
parto natural
yo tampoco alguna tuvo parto inducido
mitad y mitad hicieron que rompiera
fuente no quería epidural pero con 38
horas ya estaba cansada y sin poder y
animal que yo no quería me ocurrió a mí
a más fuerza en mi cuerpo sólo dilata
seis centímetros por eso tuvieron que
hacer arias tu cuerpo no hacía el
proceso el cordón umbilical estaba
enrollado en su cuello también mi bebé
salió azul y morado él ni siquiera lloró
cuando salió estaba tan a sandalias y le
pasó a mi bebé cuando lo escuché llorar
estaba como dime que mi bebé está bien
imagino que tu corazón se detuvo
no crees que van a llorar de inmediato
pero me voz pero lo hacen como un minuto
si todos parecíamos como madres
adolescentes conversando pasándola bien
me gusta escuchar la historia de todas
porque todos los partos son diferentes y
es bueno escucharlos creo que más de
verdad es mamá y también creo que chan a
las otras clases estaban muy calladas
hasta ahora sospecho más de keira es
sólo una corazonada lo siento mucho pero
tendré que votar por ti más llamaba
mucho la atención voy a votar por ella
de la persona que más sospechó esté acá
ya no creo que así se dice su nombre
creo que votaré por kimberly o no sé voy
a votar por kimberly tengo mis sospechas
con keila en esta ronda voy a votar
porque y la lo siento mucho pero no me
da la vibra de que ella sea mamá
están listos y tenemos un empate entre
kimberly y keila así que haremos un
desempate cada una tendrá 20 segundos
para exponer su caso
primero baqueira cuando salía embarazada
tenía 16 día luz a los 17 ahora tengo 18
años voy a la escuela y crío a mi bebé
de 10 meses mi madre fue madre
adolescente por lo que fue difícil tener
que decírselo porque sentí que estaba
siguiendo sus pasos y que le había
decepcionado por eso fue muy difícil me
enteré que estaba embarazada el 19 de
julio con mi novio me compro la prueba
de embarazo le dije a mi mamá en
realidad se enteró porque se dio cuenta
porque era muy abierta sobre mi periodo
con ella me mandó hacerme una prueba de
embarazo frente a ella y mi papá estaba
afuera del baño solo dijimos a la
escuela encontraron los recursos y pude
cambiarme a una escuela para embarazadas
y madres adolescentes
los votos para el desempate están listos
y la madre adolescente eliminada en la
primera ronda es
kayla adios lo siento amiga genuinamente
creía que una mamá adolescente vote por
keyla porque kimberley tenía una
historia sólida me hubiese gustado
quedarme más tiempo quería que vieran a
mi bebé
es una bebé muy buena sólo llora cuando
quiere dormir y si no la levanta dio la
y ahora está aprendiendo a cómo usar sus
manos como es tan pequeña no tiene sus
objetos favoritos pero le encanta coco
melón si está durmiendo y le pongo coco
melón se despierta a ver no le encantan
los animales esta niña esta niña no le
tiene miedo a nada tenemos un dragón
barbudo se llama saffron en el momento
que esa from entra nadie le gusta verle
a su cara le están saliendo los dientes
por lo que no está durmiendo de noche
por eso está despierto a esta hora estoy
en el reino unido normalmente ese año
feliz es risueño sonríe siempre habla e
interrumpe su favorito es coco melón y
le gusta ver vip y le gusta hacer
fiestas de baile o cuál es tu color
favorito rosado cuál es tu animal
favorito el moho el moho
a su animal favorito es el moho al
parecer su papá no se involucra aún así
está floreciendo le gusta comer mucho y
también ya te ha mucho ahora le gusta
hablar mucho y es
muy amigable no llora con nadie
tiene hambre sus objetos favoritos son
los unicornios disfrazarse hacerte
princesa te gustan las princesas no
no bien buena atrapada fue una lucha
quitarle el vestido de princesa hoy pero
logramos hacerlo cierto
oh sí cuando la conoce no habla mucho es
muy reservada pero eres el otro ya tengo
uno cariño me pareció genial ver a todos
los bebés todos se parecen a sus mamás
creo que todas dudarán de mí porque
tengo una niña pequeña y el resto tiene
bebés que están más apegadas a ellas no
sé si sacamos a la impostora no creo que
que y la era la impostor aún tengo mis
sospechas de kimberley yo elegiría a
kimberley
sin explicación válida yo elegiría esta
vez como lo hice antes porque dada la
situación contra las otras chicas las
otras están más calmadas que ella si
tuviera que votar por alguien ahora creo
que votaría porque ya no voy a decir que
sospecho un poco de qian ya sé cómo
decir el nombre de rihanna y creo que
ella es la más sospechosa tengo miedo
lo sabía pensé que me sacarían a mí bien
no tenía mucho que contar sobre mi hija
porque es muy pequeña las otras mamás
tenían mucho que decir pero ya veremos
pensé que quizás estaba embarazada un
par de semanas pero estaba en negocios
así que mi novio ahora mi prometido era
mi novio nes de licitaciones gracias así
que fuimos a una estación de gasolina
para comprar caramelos y golosinas para
llevarnos la al cine compré la prueba de
embarazo más barata y me la tomé en el
baño del cine cuando salí y se dio
cuenta por mi cara y me dijo estás
embarazada cierto y le dije sí y dijo
bueno ya veremos qué hacer nunca
terminamos él ha sido el mejor padre
aunque bueno y escondí mi embarazo mis
padres lo describieron y si sorpresa en
serio todo el mundo estaba como no puedo
querer casi embarazada sí pero no se
notaba nada sólo un avance es decir uno
de los trabajos todo el tiempo mientras
estuve embarazada
pudimos mantenerla así esa es mi
historia mi mamá me castigó y me metí en
problemas me quitó el teléfono y decidí
enviarle un mensaje a una amiga desde mi
computadora le conté que tenía varios
síntomas porque ella también es una mamá
adolescente y dijo si estás embarazada y
mi mamá violó es en mi teléfono ella los
leyó y después se relajó y cuando mi
papá se enteró en realidad me apoyo
mucho a mi papá es muy religioso él
piensa que las cosas pasan por ahí
gracias a los padres que nos apoyan
cuando estaba en la escuela muchos me
juzgaron y por eso me cambié a una
escuela en línea y algunas personas
hicieron vandalismo en mi casa cuando
estaba embarazada qué horrible y yo era
una perra una zorra eso es terrible
lamento que hayas pasado por eso
en junio tenía dolores menstruales pero
no me llegaba el periodo así que busqué
en google y lo primero que me salió fue
embarazo
ah le conté a mi novio y él vino a mi
casa esto fue en julio y me compró la
prueba de embarazo y me la hice a él
estaba feliz pero yo tenía una expresión
en blanco en mi cara no sabía qué pensar
no quería creerlo
llorar pero cuando veo a otras personas
llorar mis padres se enteraron en agosto
por qué
y se dieron cuenta que no me llegaba el
periodo le conté un par de amigas y me
dijeron que abortara pero yo no iba a
hacer eso mi novio y yo no estamos
juntos desde hace tres años en febrero
ahora todos conocen a mi bebé
o amiga y eso es todo estoy muy feliz de
como mi vida es ahora bien y me encantó
no la cambiaría por nada si bien yo
tenía 15 años cuando salí embarazada a
la primera persona que le conté fue
obviamente mi novio se llama zach no lo
planificamos pero estaba como tienes que
tenerlo nos llevamos bien comenzaremos
una vida juntos mis padres nos apoyaron
mucho pensaron en muchas cosas que me
podrían pasar fue asombroso el apoyo en
especial de mis padres pero luego de
cinco meses de embarazo mi novio y yo
terminamos bloqueamos la comunicación no
nos hablábamos ni nos vimos en la fecha
del parto me volvió a contactar volvimos
juntos y luego nuestro hijo nació cuatro
días después y seguimos juntos ahora
comentaré que estaba embarazada a los 15
mi escuela de preparatoria tiene un
laboratorio infantil en la escuela que
es como una guardería tienen una clínica
para adolescentes donde hacen exámenes
de embarazo y ts de todo un día que al
terminar la escuela con una de mis
amigas y me enteré que estaba embarazada
el doctor entró a la sala se paró
enfrente y yo estaba como oh no aquí
viene sí y lo subo por su expresión que
estaba embarazada y mi novio y yo
teníamos solo un mes juntos en ese
momento él tenía 14 y yo tenía 15 años
él tenía mucho miedo de decírselo a sus
padres y mis padres fueron super
comprensivos mi mamá fue madre
adolescente también afortunadamente la
escuela tiene un laboratorio infantil y
una especie de guardería puedo llevarla
conmigo y este es mi último año
felicitas y añadió graduarme no lo puedo
creer seré la primera en mi familia será
muy divertido increíble hola impostor es
muy buena actriz y ya la sacamos no
sospecho de nadie
y lo lamento voy a votar por jana en
esta ronda no quería porque realmente me
parece simpática si no hemos sacado a la
impostora me voy a molestar yo sospecho
de que era y voy a votar por ella aún
tengo muchas sospechas sobre kimberly en
los 20 segundos sobre mi su desempate
dijo que sus padres se dieron cuenta y
le compraron una prueba de embarazo como
tengo que votar por una sola votaré por
kimberly solo por el hecho que fue quien
dio menos detalles o fue poco
descriptiva creo que votaré por kimberly
no
lo siento lo siento mucho no sabía por
quién votar me siento mal lo siento creo
que votaron por mí porque estaba
llorando no se me ponga sentimental
cuando cuento mi historia levanten los
pulgares si quieren continuar el juego
si no bajen los pulgares si creen que ya
atraparon a la impostora y quieren
terminar el juego ahora mismo
esto es exasperante sí lo sé si aparece
el color verde todas ganaron si es rojo
la impostora aún continúa en el juego y
todas pierden en 3 2 1
sí sí sí lo logramos lo sabemos que nos
es muy útil
ahora tengo curiosidad quién era me
gustaría que la impostora revele quién
es en
[Música]
los increíbles
lo hiciste bien ya que es un bebé muy
lindo te felicito de quién es ese bebé
es el bebé de mi mamá
hermanito sería algo así
cuando sales la gente piensa que es tuyo
o si a veces si soy su niñera a menudo
adiós
mira adiós
[Música]